too late
you will
miss away Clark Kent Daily Planet civil
liberties are being trampled on in their
city the bat vigilante thinks he's above
the law don't believe everything you
hear self
boys Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I love
it I love bringing people together Lex
it is a pledge oh wow that is a good
grip you should not pick a fight with
this person
hey youtubers is Charlie new Batman V
Superman teaser Superman wrecking the
Batmobile without even trying
really there are two things going on
here Superman saying I'm not here to
fight you I don't want to kill you if I
could I would totally do it
look at how you ricochet off me like a
bug would Batman being like yeah I get
it but I'm still gonna make you bleed so
this is probably happening pretty early
in the movie in this other clip with Lex
Luthor in throwing them at the party
also probably from pretty early on
forget Superman's stuff for a second
Clark Kent is a reporter a pretty good
one at the Daily Planet it sounds like
he's really aware of the problems that
are plaguing all the citizens of Gotham
and metropolis especially Gotham for
that matter which looks like it was just
raised during their fight with Zod he
does imply that Batman thinks he's above
the law
and should not be but I'm wondering if
Superman thinks that he is also above
the law it looks like you know in other
trailers he's submitting himself to
Congress so I'm assuming the answer is
no he's willing to work with the
governments of the earth I think his
fear more is that they'll try to control
him which they kind of addressed during
the Man of Steel movie through the
course of their fights I'm wondering if
Batman is going to engineer some sort of
anti Kryptonian weapon Lex Luthor is
making doomsday so obviously other
people are going to be creating their
own tech - Batman has all the best toys
why wouldn't he make his kryptonite
armor look at this gun here everyone's
been asking about this you know what's
what's the deal Batman doesn't use guns
that's this big deal maybe this is some
sort of antique Kryptonian weapon Zack
Snyder was talking about his normal
armor - he said it's not so much to help
him defeat Superman it's more to give
him a couple extra seconds before
Superman crushes him like a soda can so
is like getting in a really big car
wreck at a really high speed you wear
your seatbelt so it mitigates damage for
a split second but you're still gonna
get your brains splattered all over
everything there's just too much force I
know there's always the debate who'd win
in a fight Superman or Batman it really
depends on which versions of the
characters are fighting each other
because normally Superman won't kill
people I know you know Man of Steel
snappings odds neck very controversial
but most versions of Superman and from
what it sounds like in this trailer this
version of Superman does not kill humans
Batman is human ergo Superman will
always pull his punches all the versions
of Batman do not pull their punches
which is where you get to the infamous
Krypton
ringg you get the kryptonite armor from
The Dark Knight comic book which the
aesthetic of this movie borrows heavily
from kind of that same vein I think a
better example too is the Dark Knight
three comic if you guys haven't been
reading it it's actually pretty cool but
spoiler warning I just have to talk a
little bit about Superman in that issue
so what you find out is this Superman is
encased in ice in the fortress of
solitude and you don't know why his
daughter with Wonder Woman who's half
Kryptonian looks at him and wonders
outloud why did you let them do this to
you so that just gives you an idea of
what Superman will let people get away
with I'm guessing the ben affleck batman
just doesn't have quite the amount of
toys that all the other versions of
batman have so he'll probably work his
way up to anti Kryptonian weapons that
was actually the big deal with Man of
Steel in order to do that unique
kryptonite and as a Man of Steel there
is no Kryptonite on earth but I think
the way his ex manner is gonna explain
it is that the Kryptonian terraformers
made a little bit of Kryptonite while
they were changing the earth if Luthor
can get his hands on Kryptonian tech to
build this birthing chamber then Batman
could get his hands on it to make some
weapons I think the real question in the
movie is how far things will get in this
war between Batman and Superman - like
the third act when they come together in
doomsday comes out I'm guessing he's
gonna be a third act reveal doomsday so
let me know how many encounters you
think Batman and Superman are gonna have
when they're pounding it out with each
other I'm gonna guess at least two will
call this the first time that they run
into each other where Batman's like I'm
gonna go check him out Superman looks at
them and just flies off and then the
next time they fight that and has the
full armor on in related DC universe
news there's gonna be a whole bunch of
flash arrow legends of tomorrow news
dropping tomorrow so whatever ends up
happening whatever they announce I will
totally do a video for it so be sure to
subscribe to get that it'll probably be
sometime mid day Sunday I've seen a lot
of you guys asking about a picture of
felicity in a wheelchair asking if she's
gonna be Oracle Marc Guggenheim the
showrunner on arrow posted this on
Twitter earlier so I'm guessing that the
wheelchair thing is from her
hallucination so don't don't plan on
Felicity Barbara Gordon Oracle stuff
happening in case you guys didn't see it
I just did a big Star Wars video about
the state of the
force around Episode seven you can click
here to learn all about that yeah you
can click here for all my other Batman V
Superman videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight